Imagine what would happen if you left a type
of bird — for example, finches — alone
on a lush planet without predators for hundreds
of millions of years.
What kinds of incredible forms might evolve?
If you consider that mammals grew from a few
rodent-like species into elephants, whales,
horses, bats, and primates in a much shorter
period after the extinction of dinosaurs—
you’ll start to realize just how incredible
things might get.
This concept is the idea behind one of the
most detailed speculative biology projects
ever created; Serina, the World of Birds.
This epic multi-million year journey was created
by Dylan Bajda, an incredible artist ad writer.
I have links below where you can follow and
support his work.
There’s so much incredible detail to this
project, and I won’t be able to cover it
all in a single video.
But for now, let’s get started at the very
beginning of the saga, with the introduction
of life on the moon of Serina.
The story begins when some force—perhaps
aliens or advanced humans—places earth lifeforms
on the moon of Serina.
Specifically, they put... canaries — finches
to be exact — into a terraformed ecosystem
much like earth’s.
A few other species — including grasses,
algae, flowering plants like sunflowers, tiny
fish like guppies and swordtails, and insects
like ants and crickets — are also left on
the planet to create a stable food source
for the finches — which are the only large
land animals on this entire moon.
And then, the creators of this mysterious
experiment depart, and evolution takes over.
The explosion in canary diversity is almost
instantaneous.
Badjda speculates that lacking predators and
with a near endless food supply, the population
would skyrocket over the first ten thousand
years.
From here, early specialization emerges — with
insect-eaters, plant-eaters, egg-eaters, and
seed-eaters all becoming subtly divergent
over generations.
In the sea, guppies and swordtails grow and
diversify.
Over the next several million years, which
is called the Hypostecene, the small fish
will become larger and more streamlined — with
hydrodynamics shaping them into familiar forms.
Several million years in, and leafcutter ants
have quickly proliferated, with their numbers
reaching tens of billions.
Soon, larger flightless variants of canaries
emerge to feed on this emerging food source.
As the sun rises 10 million years in, a true
ecosystem of different species is forming.
Here, the thick-beaked axbills strut across
the plains, near the large womblers and long-legged
aardgeese.
Already, the moon of Serina is a much different
place from when these birds first arrived.
And from here, things will only get stranger…
11 million years in, an era call the Tempuscene
begins, marked by a steady cooling and an
increase in arid environments.
At fifteen million years, a region called
the Northern Drylands comprises the largest
temperate desert region on this moon, where
all sorts of new species are emerging.
It’s now early spring here, and a large
and lithe aardgoose offshoot is strutting
across the Drylands — keeping an eye on
the fearsome descendants of the formerly herbivorous
Axbills called the Skykes, which are now sharp
billed omnivores.
Nearby, one of the first true predators, the
small Falconary, hunts a songbird under the
branches of huge, tree-like sunflower descendants.
But below them all, in a series of tunnels,
an even more interesting dynamic is unfolding.
These tunnels are made by an enormous lobster-like
arthropod, which despite weighing as much
as a small cat, is in fact a cricket.
And with it in its home are strange little
birds called ground serins.
They can’t dig tunnels themselves, but make
use of the friendly crickets’ burrow to
keep themselves safe, and in return act as
lookouts.
A very strange set of roommates indeed.
As the Tempuscenic Era progresses, Serina
continues to cool.
In this changing environment, the artist imagines
one successful branch of Aardgeese, called
the ‘vivas,’ is on the path of a surprising
adaptation: the birth of live young without
requiring an egg.
In the coming ice age, this adaptation will
prove vital to the branch’s success.
Away from the mainland, however, the isolated
Kyran Islands are not yet feeling the effects
of the global cooling.
On these islands — where food grows in abundance
and predators are scarce — very different
selective pressures are creating some of the
largest, and strangest, species of birds so
far.
Reaching heights of over ten feet, the chubbirds
are huge offshoots of finches that don’t
resemble any other birds on Serina at this
time.
In this paradise, there’s simply nothing
big enough on these islands to bother them.
In time, though, the islands change.
The chubbirds pass on, and in their place
an even stranger species of megafauna emerge
— better suited for the islands’ new grassier
ecosystem.
These are the snuffalos: shaggy, heavyset
creatures almost the size of cattle — and
with a similar grazing behavior.
The snuffalos are so heavy, however, that
they can’t support their weight on their
two feet alone, and must also rely on their
beak for balance, which has become almost
a third foot.
Inefficient?
Perhaps, but there are few predators on these
islands that would make the snuffalo require
speed.
Save perhaps, for one.
The butcherraptor is an evolutionary newcomer
to the world of Serina, and not large enough
to seem like a threat to something suffalo-sized.
But the butcherraptor has something the snuffalo
does not: intelligence.
Butcherraptors are quite possibly the smartest
creatures Serina has yet to produce, efficient
pack hunters that can, in a group, take down
something as big as a snuffalo.
And in the oceans, life is also diversifying
into unexpected forms.
Take, for example, the Swordsharks: predators
whose swordtail ancestors averaged six inches
in length.
The swordshark, in contrast, averages up to
eight feet — and preys on vast shoals of
smaller fish, thrashing them with their unique
tails to stun them.
An even more incredible transformation has
occurred in the case of the Giant Gemnus,
a guest entry into Serina conceptualized by
Joseph Cawley.
The Giant Gemnus grows over thirty feet, or
9 meters in length, and consumes over 400
pounds, or 180 kilos of plant-matter a day.
And yet, the ancestors of these herbivorous
behemoths… are the tiny guppies.
Truly aquatic birds called Bloons also emerge
during the Tempuscene — like the starry
Pelecarrier, a species that incubates eggs
under its hind legs and carries its young
safely in its mouth.
Right now, these early seafaring birds are
far from the largest things in the sea: about
the size of a human diver.
In the future, however, the circumstances
of the Bloons would change…
However, it’s not the Bloons, nor even the
Giant Gemnus that one should be keeping an
eye on long-term.
These tiny, unfortunate, almost-toad looking
creatures are called mudwickets.
They’re a species of fish that lives in
tidal areas and are beginning the process
of crawling onto land.
Right now, they aren’t up too much, but
there are many millions of years to go in
our great epic...
Looking back on Serina’s progress, 50 million
years have now passed since the introduction
of the canaries, and the moon is now entering
a period called the Cryocene.
The climate, already cooling in the Tempuscene,
has now cooled further and over half the moon’s
surface is locked in ice.
In this new frontier, the live-bearing vivas
group have come to dominate all manner of
niches: both at the equator and in the colder
regions.
From the large topical shimmersnoot vivas
who eat insects with their long tongues, to
the lithe herbivorous serilopes and thick-beaked
carnivorous banshees of the plains, to the
tiny bumblets who burrow underground to keep
warm — the vivas have become one of the
most diverse groups in this new world.
Another successful vivas is the Canaribou
— large, thick-coated offshoots of serilopes
that live in enormous migratory herds and
can withstand the harsh polar winters in this
region.
The Canaribou is the first true live-bearing
bird, giving birth to fully hatched infants.
Here, a mother protects its newborn from a
Giant Falconry — aerial predators that have
grown fully gigantic over the ages, but not
so large they’re ready to tangle with an
angry mother protecting its young.
In the tall forests of pineflowers (plants
which have evolved conifer-like needles),
however, the more familiar descendants of
egg-laying species hold on.
In this more temperate region, the giant flightless
anvilbeak, with a beak that helps it crack
open all manner of seeds, lives near its cousins,
the swordbills — who are lightweight hunters.
These holdovers are the distant descendants
of the axbills, and in these forests, their
lineage will endure through the cooling trends.
Another familiar (though increasingly strange)
species are the molebirds — the descendants
of burrowing finches who, instead of relying
on the tunnels of others, are capable diggers
in their own right.
For millions of years they’ve quietly tunneled
underground, content to be ignored by the
above ground megafauna.
Also much changed since our last visit are
the aquatic Bloons, which are now one of the
most specialized lineages of birds on Serina.
Growing to more than sixty feet (18 meters)
in length and weighing up to fifteen thousand
pounds (6800 kg) the artist describes them
as a family of gentle, herbivorous leviathans
— and the largest birds to have ever existed.
This particular species, the Emperor Bloons,
have been nicknamed the ‘birdwhales’ — and
you can likely imagine why.
And at the water’s edge, the unassuming
mudwickets have continued to adapt, spending
more and more time on land.
They still don’t look like much, but soon,
circumstances will change...
But the time of the mudwickets is not yet
upon us.
Jumping forwards to the late Cryocene — the
final period we’ll be covering in this particular
video — we’ve arrived at an age…. of
giants.
On the plains, one large offshoot of the serilope
are the flutterboks, colorful herbivores with
a colorful plumage similar in many ways to
the feathers of earth’s peacocks.
The flutterboks are in turn stalked by the
dinosaur-like Trunksnouts — whose newly
evolved pseudo-teeth make them effective predators…
with a high degree of evolutionary potential.
Even more dinosaur-like are the Serestriders,
the largest terrestrial bird that has yet
to evolve on Serina.
Exceeding 12 meters or 40 feet in height and
weighing several tons, the Serestriders are
the sauropods of their day, adapted to browse
the highest branches of trees.
Here, a solitary bull serestrider wanders
peacefully in the shade — content in the
knowledge that few species can match it.
But larger herbivores mean larger carnivores.
The Tyrant Serins, the grandest of all descendants
of the distant axbeak, are apex predators
that can take down other large megafauna.
Equipped with serrated beaks able to shatter
bone, these tyrants are the heaviest land
predators yet to evolve.
This period is an early peak of megafauna
on Serina — which now supports species so
large and distinct they’re almost unrecognizable
when one reflects on the moon’s first, humble
inhabitants.
Over the next several million years, Serina
would change once again, as an increase in
volcanic eruptions on a larger scale than
ever before would turn the environment on
its head, giving rise to far more alien-looking
creatures than ever before, which we’ll
explore in our next installment.
But for now, that’s all the time we have.
For now, if you enjoyed learning about the
moon of Serina, consider following and supporting
Dylan Bajda using the links below.
Also, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.